two options you either follow my rules  or follow my rules  capiche thank you I can do it a  different way oh that's that's fine  thank you very much  your fire it's Christmas yeah I see the  decorations good luck in the new year  I just heard you play and I want Prince  James that we keep running into each  other maybe it means something I doubt  it yeah you could just write your own  roles you know write something that's as  interesting as you are what are you  gonna do  and my own Club  that can happen every time I think so  how are you gonna be a revolutionary if  it's such a traditionalist  you holding on to the past but jazz is  about the future yes maybe I'm not it's  like a pipe dream  this is the dream it's conflict and it's  compromise it's very very exciting